[Music]
hello again it's time for dear drew
because we are not skipping a beat this
summer we love opening and reading all
of your mail
it always feels like you're reaching out
and giving us a warm hug
via the usps
and getting letters from my kids at camp
i mean i cry i do it means so much to me
so i'd like to honor today's zip code it
is 37403
chattanooga tennessee
that rhymes i'm just saying
it's home of the first patented
miniature golf course created in
1927.
throughout the city there are various
doors that lead to nowhere windows that
open to brick walls and underground
tunnels called underground chattanooga
chattanooga tennessee we would love to
hear from you send us some mail now
let's get to our first letter
you know i don't read these beforehand
they're all spontaneous okay
dear mr barrymore
your movie's like scream ever after
charlie's angels donnie darko and whip
it have had such a profound impact on me
thank you
i live my life like your character
danielle and ever after okay
i strive to do what's right and speak up
for those who can't i've been in your
audience a few times and it lifted my
spirits like your movies
i've enclosed a gift and hope you like
it a small business pentagram peter
created mashups and i felt compelled to
send you this one sarah chattanooga
tennessee
this screen really did change my life um
when i auditioned for e.t i had to come
back well first i interviewed for
poltergeist and steven spielberg told me
i wasn't right for it which broke my
heart but then he said come back i'm
making another movie which was called
the boy's life it wasn't called e.t at
that time
and i came in for several auditions and
the final one was to see if i could
scream
this moment really did change my life
it's a good thing i can scream because i
don't know if i'd be sitting here today
if i couldn't
thank you so much for this beautiful
shirt i really appreciate it but much
more importantly sarah it made me like
tear up when i heard you loved ever
after because i got to tell you of all
the characters i've ever gotten to play
danielle is the one who taught me the
most you rescue yourself you still want
love and
you know to be around friends and
everything at the end of the day but
it's like you are the one in charge of
your destiny you know we're all given
that cinderella tale like wait to be
rescued no you rescue yourself and then
you go live your life
changed everything for me so i'm glad
you like it too thank you sarah i'm
going to write you a little postcard
back
i'd usually sign it truly yours drew but
i'm going to sign this one truly yours
danielle
then yeah
thank you
[Music]